Val Chmerkovskiy cozies up to a fellow  Dancing with the Stars Pro and et has  all the adorable pics  I love to love I love to love seems like  love is definitely in the air for the 29  year old and his fellow Dancing with the  Stars Pro Jenna Johnson after a day of  dance rehearsals the duo was spotted  having a romantic lunch date in LA full  of plenty of PDA the 21 year old sweetly  caressed vows face at the table and  later he returned the affection holding  Jenna's hand and wrapping his arm around  her on their way out a source tells ET  the flirty pair have actually been  dating on and off for years judging by  these new pics that seems like things  have heated up once again  you